bon je te faire une interview coq à
l'âne est ce que tu préfères être un coq
ou bien un âne je préfère encore être ce
que je suis mieux que je sois pas
terrible est ce que tu as déjà pensé au
suicide
oui enfin c'est à dire j'ai l'impression
que ma vie est un lent suicide est ce
que tu crois qu'il faut coucher pour
réussir
moi je crois pas du tout je crois que
quand quelqu'un un vrai talent il
réussit forcément qu'est ce que tu veux
de plus sexy en toi eh bien j'aimerais
beaucoup de savoir c'est une petite voix
me le dire ça me rendrait service et de
-2 sexy tout il ya l'embarras du choix
je pense que son maison de pied de ce
que j'ai fait tomber une grosse valise
dessus une fois et puis maintenant il
pousse pas très bien à croire connais-tu
infailliblement la passion naissante
chez moi ou chez quelqu'un de chez toi
c'est ça se reconnaît au fait que
subitement on peut plus passer d'une
présence et la passion qui s'éteint
qu'on peut s'en passer kita découverte
professionnellement je la personne qui
m'a qui m'a signé mon premier contrat
c'est jacques bolson qui reste est un
ami et sexe et hellmand sexuellement
la première personne qui est vraiment
compté pour moi c'est jean marie périer
c'est pas un secret est-ce que tu
m'aimes j'aime surtout d'autres genres
certaines personnes d'une manière de pas
penser un ac mais où elle passait mais
les cours est sûr de ne rien rater de il
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux